les gars on va faire un petit jeu c'est
un micro ça on va faire un petit jeu
turin mais hier il est là thierry tu vas
dire avec moi j'essaie de te mettre un
tir trois possibilités se consacrer une
coque si les gens mais peindre
j'irai aux cages et vous ferez ce que
vous voudrez vous ferait plaisir c'est
pas
on a trois ballons thierry omeyer
j'ai allaité champion d'europe champion
du monde champion olympique à d'accord
ok j'ai droit d'aller jusque où j'ai
travaillé jusqu'au bout a dit m quoi tu
ce cas là une surface de boulettes je
connais bien d'accord c'est une émission
rien c'est juste leur vision mais
attends attends attends pas dire jusque
là attention attentat c'est ça c'est ça
le très noir le très noir très noir six
mois de ses six mètres
car vous attire alors d'accord le
meilleur des défenseurs aly luca un
petit avec 1 c'est vrai ça c'est le
passé par ses applaudissements pour
drive un peu d'histoire pendant mme
baehler allez vas-y ou c est quoi vous
avez montré trop c'est parti comme ça
moi je prends simplement pas tort quand
c'est pour les chiottes away dans les
mains dans les choix éthiques
en fait le vrai dire on fait tirer les
petits d'avoir des gens me saluent sur
des bleus très bon été
au courant qu'on t'a
ah bien distincts
silencieux
attendez vous
la police 400 et bravo à vous souvenir
regard des souvenirs
aulas qui a fait ça oui merci a tous
appelés sport